et pour en parler philippe verbeke
secrétaire général de la fédération
force ouvrière cheminots nous a rejoint
sur ce plateau philippe herreweghe
bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation des lectures rt france
pour commencer votre réaction à ce que
vous vous attendiez à ce que le
gouvernement dégaine le 49-3 maintenant
alors effectivement sur le maintenant
non sur le fait qu'il dégagerait 49,3
oui effectivement un peu surpris le
gouvernement ces derniers jours avaient
envahi l'espace de communication sur le
coronavirus il décrète un conseil des
ministres spécial coronavirus samedi et
finalement à la sortie de celui-ci
sa première réaction c'est à chaud à
l'assemblée nationale d'annoncé un
passage en force de son projet de loi
par le 49-3 donc oui effectivement
surpris de la méthode
après nous on appelle ça un déni de
démocratie et de démocratie on le
confirme même sur sur tout ce qui est
autour de ce projet de loi on n'a connu
que deux ans de concertation où il n'y a
pas eu d' écoute des partenaires sociaux
donc premier déni de démocratie
ensuite les organisations syndicales ont
fait savoir qu'elle appellerait une
grève début décembre et cela annoncé au
mois de septembre
aucun contact entre le gouvernement et
les organisations syndicales dans la
période de post grève
ensuite on a connu la grève on a connu
également un conseil d'état qui a estimé
que le projet de loi était lacunaire
on a découvert effectivement un projet
avec autant de trous qui lie à
d'articles donc tout ça ce sont bien des
dénis de démocratie
il ya trois français sur quatre
aujourd'hui qu'ils rejettent ce projet
de loi c'est aussi un déni de démocratie
donc écouter effectivement pas surpris
mais on appelle ce gouvernement à la
raison on a observé ces derniers jours
en tout cas un climat délétère au sein
de l'als de l'assemblée nationale est ce
qu'avec une telle atmosphère selon vous
les débats auraient plus poursuivre
finalement oui bien sûr moi je pense que
l'erreur du gouvernement c'est de
vouloir aller plus vite
que la partition eux
et de toute façon ce qui nous dérange
profondément c'est le fait de pas
entendre les français qui aujourd'hui
demandent le rejet de ce projet de
réforme est donc force ouvrière
notamment dit encore aujourd'hui retrait
de ce projet de loi
nous n'acceptons pas le système par
points oui parce qu'effectivement on le
rappelle l'utilisation du 49-3 ne signe
toutefois pas l'adoption définitive d'un
seul de ce texte ni la fin du parcours
législatif de la réforme des retraites
par conséquent l'exécutif pour encore
faire marche arrière selon vous oui bien
sûr je pense qu'aujourd'hui les français
restent déterminés quoi qu'on en dise il
n'y a pas de fissure syndicales les
organisations syndicales qui s'opposent
à ce projet reste dans l'opposition
et aujourd'hui on voit même monsieur
bergé qui commence à douter de sa
capacité à tirer vers le haut ce projet
de réforme puisque aujourd'hui on se
rend bien compte qu'après xx e semaine
de conférences temps sur le financement
que sur la pénibilité
aujourd'hui les éléments n'avance pas le
gouvernement reste sourd et le
gouvernement une nouvelle fois vient de
démontrer qu'il voulait passer en force
ce projet de loi donc je vous dis nous
la mobilisation elle continue
aujourd'hui vont se réunir beaucoup de
français autour des préfectures et
notamment à paris ce soir place de la
république pour encore affiché
l'opposition à ce projet de réforme
alors justement vous lisiez il ya des
réunions aujourd'hui des réunions
intersyndicales notamment à quoi peut-on
s'attendre dans les prochains jours
comme type de mobilisation ont coûté
peut-être une nouvelle journée d'action
cette semaine par la grève et la
manifestation
après la fédération fo cheminots est
attaché à la grève reconductible
les grèves perlées c'est pas forcément
ce qu on le revendique donc on espère
c'est que d'un point de vue
interprofessionnelle on va tout mettre
en oeuvre pour réorganiser la grève
reconductible pour que ce soit une
grande gagnante alors avec une nouvelle
donne des rassemblements de plus de cinq
mille personnes qui sont désormais
interdits dans le contexte d'épidémie du
coronavirus est-ce que ça va obliger
finalement les organisations à s'adapter
différemment dans leur mode de
contestation
nous ce qu'on pense qui va être original
avec ce compteur à 5000
c'est que pour une fois les chiffres de
la police seront plus près de celles des
organisations syndicales
c'est qu'on va bien compter les gens
pour pouvoir dire vous êtes de trop pour
vous réunir donc je pense que si
aujourd'hui c'est le coronavirus qui
prend le pas sur cette réforme de
retraites
eh bien écoutez nous on marchera pas à
cette combine on fera valoir notre droit
on sollicitera les préfectures pour
demander à ce que les rassemblements et
les manifestations se tiennent
c'est en milieu ouvert extérieur donc on
a bien autorisé un match de foot la
semaine dernière je vois pas pourquoi on
interdirait les français de manifester
contre ce projet de loi est ce que ce
49,3 au fond va davantage attisé la
colère selon vous des français
aujourd'hui
oui bien sûr ça s'est vu ce week-end les
réactions via les médias via les réseaux
sociaux
effectivement ça ça confirme bien ce
gouvernement que beaucoup jugent de plus
en plus un peu d'amateurs quand on
n'arrive pas à convaincre sa majorité du
bon sens de sa réforme
on le voit très bien aujourd'hui on a
des députés qui démissionnent on a des
sénateurs de l arm qui démissionne on a
des maires aujourd'hui qui cache
l'étiquette elles mêmes en espérant
pouvoir être élu aux municipales
c'est vraiment un gouvernement qui est à
mal donc nous on ne lâchera pas sur
cette opposition
merci beaucoup philippe herreweghe
d'avoir accepté notre invitation je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
général de la fédération fo cheminots
merci à vous